joining us right now fresh off of
winning
on thursday night football fresh off of
taking care of business for the seattle
seahawks
uh friend of the program jamal adams how
are you sir
oh my god my god how you doing man i am
better for talking
to you um how
is life for you jamal in the pacific
northwest
yeah man it's uh it's very mellow very
chill i can tell you that
um life is great out here man i'm i'm
enjoying it
um it's definitely something different
um i've never experienced in my life
you know being from dallas and obviously
you know being in new york um
everything was fast paced um no sleep
a little bit of everything out there so
i'm enjoying it man i'm loving this team
i'm loving this organization and uh we
had a big win last night and
man we needed it we needed it because it
gave us it gave us our confidence back
man
so the confidence because of the two
losses in a row
is that what you're referring to that
you needed that win you know i just
yeah you know mainly i speak for the for
the defense man i think the defense we
played our best game
you know um i think we played our best
overall game since the atlanta game um
should i say and that was the first game
of the season
um but you know everybody you know this
defense is
is everybody's new right and everybody's
trying to figure out
who can do what um you know
communication wise and
who can make the plays who can do this
who can do that um so we're all gelling
together man and it took some time and
i thought last night we came out and we
executed um we had it on our mind
throughout the week um and obviously
just wanted to come out and put on a
show and
we did a hell of a job man i had bobby
wagner on the show a few weeks ago he's
going to have a jacket one day
for canton oh absolutely absolutely it
just but
you could sense a little bit uh in his
voice you know because i've i've spoken
him before
that the defense is just not what he's
used to in terms of the
production in terms of the shutdown
ability and
last night looked as close to a seattle
seahawks defense
as before so how do you work with bobby
how have you been
handing glove with with the guy right at
the center from
from seattle jamal yeah absolutely man
he's like you said he's a hell of a
player um but not only that he's a hell
of a person
um and he's a guy that comes to work he
has the same attitude each and every day
and
he he he comes in there and he he works
his tail off
um he's always giving out you know
information trying to help you know
other guys around him
um and i love playing with him um you
know he feeds off of me just
just as much as i feed off of him um you
know we're
like i said a little while back you know
it's like batman and robin man so
anytime we are billeting together um
that's something that you know we
we get happy about when our when our
numbers are called at the same time
and you know we just try to perform it
you know at a high level
and uh in terms of the staff there uh
jamal
uh my the first uh colleague of mine at
nfl network
when we started in 2003 my analyst
on every single show is ken norton jr
kenny
okay oh yeah i'm going way back way
way back like 17 years north yeah
yeah and cool man it's my world exactly
and
interestingly enough pete carroll came
on as the usc coach one day
and asked ken norton to stroll out to
the parking lot with him
and uh sure enough he hired him
literally like later on that week and
there they've kind of been attached at
the hip how has this staff
welcomed you jamal to keep you as
comfortable as possible to let you
do what you do in this defense right
yeah man they're they're doing a you
know outstanding job
um obviously you know they're still
trying to figure out me
just as much as i'm still trying to
figure out the defense and everything
right
you know me missing four games um that
kind of put me behind the eight ball and
then obviously been dealing with
injuries
and whatnot but you know we're we're
putting it together man we're figuring
it out um as
a team and um you know they're not
pressing me to
you know do something that i'm not you
know
supposed to do they're not asking me to
do all of this they're
not putting pressure on me man so and
i'm not putting pressure on myself you
know obviously you know like i said i've
been coming down with these injuries and
been playing through it but
um you know we're you know it's just
setting up for
for the future it's setting it up for
for the playoffs down the road and
um when when when we all put it together
um it's coming along like i said
last night we we we showcased that um
and
when it really really comes all all
along we get everybody back healthy
it's gonna be special man and when you
say they don't put pressure on it's just
like when you freelance when you
when you do your thing when you do your
jamaal adams thing
which sometimes um you know uh is is
outside of the box literally
figuratively
um right they don't say anything to you
and they just
let let you go i mean what what does
that mean yeah i mean yeah
pete's all about you know he comes to me
all the time and he says you know just
go
make the play you know what i mean just
just go make the play but
you know obviously you know like i said
man uh this shoulder injury you know
kind of slowed me down a little bit
um you know i only had like what 90 72
hours
uh to a quick turnaround just to you
know fight through the pain and
uh you know uh figure it out uh but at
the end of the day man
it's it's coming along i'm not i'm not
worried about you know
what everybody's saying outside um i
hear about it from
from my boys back home of what people
say but
at the end of the day man i'm just going
to continue to do my job
continue to do what they asked me to do
and continue to learn man that's all i
can do
um obviously i'm not this is my first
year into the defense
um and you know been been battling a
couple things but
we'll be fine man i'm not worried i'm
happy about the win last night it was a
big
one uh we took we took back you know our
belt in the nfc
uh you know so that that that's
important man that's that's our number
one goal and
uh you know that's what we're focused on
jamal adams pro bowl safety
of the seattle seahawks fresh off of a
big thursday night football win right
here on the rich eisen show okay jamal
you remember the last time we saw each
other right you remember that
yes sir in south florida super bowl week
right yep
uh do you remember what i said to you do
you remember what i said to you jamal
that night
remember what i said to you you did i i
i remember i remember man it just
happened so fast man
no it's okay look again just to remind
everybody uh it's a quarterback phrase
it's a quarterback phrase called check
with me right um
i asked you i i sensed what was going on
i knew it
um i said that you were not allowed to
leave the jets without checking with me
and um
you know you didn't check with me jamal
um you didn't check with man i apologize
you know um it seems that everything's
working out for you
uh but i do want to ask you about this
question this this statement that you
made to
uh a podcast um all things covered
you said you fought depression in new
york jamal
what do you mean by that yeah i
definitely did man um
you know that's something that i you
know i came out and i said and
not too many people understood that not
to me not too many people uh
really seen that um because i you know i
smile so much and i have so much energy
i'm always you know kind of hiding
behind a you know
a mirror should i say uh
yeah man i i did i went through it i i
fought it
um nothing suicidal uh but
it was it was more so just man just
everything was
was it was it was a dark it was a dark
place out there um
you know i had to go to how to you know
sometimes
go to work and just to go to work and
and be
you know focused and be positive
around my teammates i had to walk into
the building with headphones on just to
blast music and you know positive tunes
had to
listen to podcasts and do certain things
just to get my mind right but
i was still in a dark place man just
losing so much and
um it was taking a toll on my own on not
only myself but it was taking a toll on
um my life outside of football um
you know as far as you know my family um
my relationships and whatnot
my faith with the man upstairs um and it
was it was taking a toll on me man it
was it was tough i was fighting through
it
um but like i said man it got to the
point to where i couldn't do it anymore
i tried i tried everything in my power
um
to change that organization and um like
i said man i wish them nothing but the
best
i have no hate towards anybody um you
know in that organization
i still pull for him uh believe it or
not i'm always watching
and i still pull for my guys over there
man and
um man it just it just wasn't the place
for me you know what i mean and
i wanted it to be um as bad as i wanted
to you know
figure it out i couldn't do it by myself
and um
i fought it man i i really did i really
did and you know to to
to the to the great fans like yourself
um a fan of
a fan of minds i appreciate you um
because
it was it was something that i you know
i didn't want to talk about
i never want to come out and you know
tell the world about that but i really
did
uh fight depression out there um but
like i said man i wish them nothing but
the best
um and you know we'll see him in about
three weeks yes you will
also yes you will that's gonna be it
that's gonna be a fun one man
well i because i've told this to you
before i might as well just reiterate it
here
um as we're as we're having this
conversation jamal adams on the rich
housing show
so many jets fans looked at you
yeah um as the culture changer that you
were going to go into the locker room
and tell everybody this is the way it
needs to be done
you're the alpha you're the dog you're
the guy that's going to go in there and
change it and it seemed like the culture
was unchangeable to the point where
you're even hearing members of the media
tell trevor lawrence
if the jets choose you you shouldn't
come would you i know i'm going to put
you on the spot here but i'll you you're
used to it
yeah would you would you counsel trevor
lawrence not to go to the jets if they
draft him
jamal well you know i had
somebody asked me this not too long ago
when it did come out right
i would say this i would say this um
first off if you're the number one pick
uh you
you have to take it so it's just not
it wouldn't be smart for him to not you
know
go as the number one pick that's how we
look at it
um yeah it's gonna be a tough situation
um but you know i i don't know man i
i don't want to say that it can't be
turned around
um but it has to it has to be
a lot of changes um from top to bottom
and
that's just what it is man uh they have
a lot of they have
a great fan base um even though they
they kill me on anything i do that not
you know up to par uh but it is what it
is man i
like i said man i i talked to uh beats
him last last night obviously he plays
with arizona now and
one of my one of my favorite teammates i
ever played with um
og in the game and you know just just
hearing guys that that were
a part of that organization while i was
there um
just saying how proud they are of me of
just sticking to my worth and speaking
up
and you know believing in myself and i
and i am proud of myself and i i always
be proud of myself you know a lot of
people didn't think
a 24 year old would bet on his career
and move up move somewhere else and and
take on a challenge and
i go through a challenge each and every
day and i understand that
you know i was the guy over there um
well
i i once was the guy because now i'm i'm
i'm nobody to them right now right so
um but it's still it's still all love
and respect um
at the end of the day i understand that
fans are hurt
um with the jets and i get that um but i
had to do what was best for
myself uh and my family and and i'll be
honest with you jamal i mean not many
safeties
net what you netted the jets in return i
mean that is
that is um that that's a testament to
your talent
uh in itself and so you do wish them all
the best it's not week 14.
that's for sure no no no definitely not
what does that calendar look like
do you have a calendar with a date
actually circled jamal
does that exist somewhere hey listen i
cannot wait for that game
uh that game is going to be wow it's
going to be it's gonna be special but
i'll tell you what i'm not gonna make it
bigger than what it is right
i know that the media is gonna try to
you know um
you know jab at me in in every way in
every angle
um so i'm looking forward to it man i'm
not
again man i'm really not worried about
you know
what everybody's saying the pff ratings
and
all of this and that man i just want to
do whatever i can
you know whatever i can to help this
team win and um
you know just continue to get better
continue to learn the defense um and
i'll be fine man these guys have my back
over here
um and i appreciate them more than they
more than they know
you know what i mean and i have i have a
great
circle of uh brothers back home a great
family
great parents brothers and sisters
nieces nephews
uh that support me and that's all i
really need i don't i don't i'm not out
here to try to prove anybody
wrong i'm always trying to prove myself
right you know what i mean so that's
what i'm about man
hey man jamal uh pff um tweeted out
uh you've got 17 total pressures five
and half sacks both lead the seahawks
right now
and you missed wow they tweeted that yes
they did there's no way there's no way
they tweeted something positive about me
this year
they just didn't at you they didn't add
pres okay okay okay
yeah i had it i i got off a twitter rich
you know i mean i i just got back on
last night i was on
twitter for about two weeks okay um yeah
just uh just just to stay focused man
because it's
it's a lot of negative out there okay
you know but i i'm glad they tweeted
something positive
man i i salute them for that yeah both
lead the seahawks yeah there you go
there's no no doubt about that and i
guess last one for you uh
russell uh he's a special he's a special
human
um being around him what's your first
blush impression of him and being around
him and seeing how he operates
oh man ultimate competitor um russ and i
talk
you know every day um he helps me in
many ways
and i hope i help him in many ways as
well how does he help you
but we feed off each other how does he
help you uh just
just just mentally you know what i mean
just on the mental side of
you know just if you do have a bad play
or
or you do you do have a bad game um or
you miss a few
you know opportunities you know just
keep going just keep swinging you know
what i mean
it's more glory days down you know down
the road
you know the storm the storm it won't
last forever
right and you know he took so much so
much criticism
over the past two or three weeks um you
know about his
turnovers and he came to work each and
every day
positive fighting you know still going
out
going to work still being rushed and
then he goes out there and he
he proves who he is once again and as
long as you you keep your mindset
focused on the prize you can't worry
about the outside you can't worry about
what they say about you
if you just stay focused on the marathon
you'll be fine man
and i always talk about it rest in peace
the mipsy hustle um the marathon
continues
you know what i mean no matter what you
go through no matter the ups and downs
the injuries
the the losses the lessons whatever you
go through in life
you got to keep going because the
marathon continues you know so
i i appreciate i call him three i always
call him three so i appreciate three
more than anything uh because he's a
special guy and
not only that he's a special human jamal
even though you didn't check with me
i still i'm still here for you i'm sorry
that's okay
it's all right you know i was looking
down at my phone next hey when i come
when i come to new york man
let's go grab some lunch man when the
cobia ends man let's let's do let's do
it
i'm also down the coast in los angeles
let's do it if you're ever in l.a
you reach out to me i'm here check check
with me is all i'm saying
you know even though you don't check
with your brother i'm going to get over
it and i miss you jamal and all
everybody does every single week man
every week but
i appreciate you brother always good to
see you balling out thanks for the call
uh get get uh get better in that uh mini
buy you'd be well
i appreciate you brother thank you man
right back at you that's jamal adams
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here